[Music]
and breaking news out of china tonight
after beijing reportedly launching what
is a hypersonic missile into orbit and
one by the way that can carry nuclear
weapons and mocking america's sense of
quote strategic superiority now while
china's denying the report this apparent
nuclear-capable space technology
reportedly caught the u.s intel
community completely off guard one
source telling the financial times we
have no idea how they did this with the
white house and circle back
propagandists jen saki saying they
remain mostly mum but we we welcome
quote stiff competition really you
welcome the reunification of taiwan too
china is passing the u.s joe on your
watch what are you going to do about it
as they are increasingly targeting
taiwan continue to talk about and
threaten what they're calling
reunification flying their fighter jets
over taiwan airspace and of course just
another example of biden projecting his
utter weakness on the world stage and
sending a message not just to our
adversaries all our allies as well that
the united states of america is asleep
and in retreat don't take my word for it
just listen to former obama defense
secretary robert gates saying that biden
has gotten pretty much uh everything
wrong on foreign policy take a look
you wrote joe biden was a man of
integrity still i think he's been wrong
in nearly every major foreign policy and
national security issue over the past
four decades i think he's gotten a lot
wrong you're talking all through the
years as vice president and he's opposed
every one of ronald reagan's military
programs to uh contest the soviet union
he opposed the first gulf war that list
goes on but do you think he made a
mistake in afghanistan in the way
he handled the withdrawal yes here with
reactions uh senator lindsey graham
south carolina senator i don't know
about you but you know when i hear we
welcome the stiff competition
and we're watching now hypersonic
missiles that have nuclear capability
being fired around the globe and talk a
reunification with china and chinese
fighter jets flying over taiwan airspace
and joe does nothing
uh why should why should the chinese
fear joe biden i don't see any reason
why they would
well what does it matter to the people
at home listening to this program if in
fact the chinese have developed a
hypersonic missile that can deliver a
nuclear weapon it's a military game
changer when it comes to
nuclear forces we've allowed the chinese
to leapfrog us and we're in we're going
to have to do one of two things get them
to stand down and i don't know how joe
biden convinces anybody to stand down
and if they don't stand down we're going
to have to develop a capability to
neutralize this and what up china so
when you have the joe biden greatest hit
list broken border rise of terrorism
rampant inflation you can now put on the
list nuclear arms race with china which
we're losing weakness breeds aggression
and i'm going to ask the the senate
leadership schumer and mcconnell
to brief the entire body on whether or
not this story is true if this is true
the chinese have developed this
capability it's the biggest game changer
in the last 40 years when it comes
uh to our nuclear well
let's look at this from china's point of
view they already compromised the bidens
i'm sure if libya knew all about
hunter's drug addiction and and
proclivity and love of of prostitutes
i'm sure that communist chinese know
even more so i think the family's
compromise the billion five is a lot of
money with the bank of china but it's 78
days senator since joe biden promised
not to abandon americans in afghanistan
it's 65 days since he abandoned them
it's 45 days since he's ever mentioned
them you tell me if if the communist
chinese are watching
joe biden abandon his own citizens after
promising not to in afghanistan why
would joe biden lift a finger to help
taiwan
i conclude he wouldn't well if i meant
well i think the chinese are testing
them at every corner and every day we
allow the iranians to get more
provocative without pushing back every
day we allow americans to be in the
hands of the taliban every day that
al-qaeda gets stronger you know the
taliban told us apparently they have no
interest and will not cooperate in terms
of regulating al qaeda's presence in
afghanistan they basically told us to go
to hell so the chinese are watching the
iranians are watching and here's what
iran's watching
well you know what you blinked when it
came to
uh to afghanistan you turned the place
over to terrorism um i'm waiting at the
iranians
you're forgetting a critical point is
they've already given the islamic
emirates of afghanistan 65 million
dollars they are negotiating they're
saying they're business-like and
professional and negotiating aid for
the islamic emirates of afghanistan
while we still have americans and green
card holders and allies caught behind
enemy lines where i grew up senator
probably a lot different than when you
grew up in a far more gentile south
carolina but in new york we call that
ransom and we call that a shakedown
exactly so i think what you're going to
see is you're going to see a provocative
iran now worry a lot about israel we
they may be left to deal with iran by
themselves because why wouldn't the
iranians try to break out and have a
nuclear weapon and hold the whole world
hostage if it's true that the chinese
communist party has leapfrogged us in
terms of nuclear technology uh then god
help us all what is joe biden doing you
welcome the competition you don't say
that you tell china stand down or you
will regret this
and did he say stand down no he says we
welcome competition no we do not welcome
the chinese communist party with a
hypersonic uh missile that can hit the
american homeland and neutralize all of
our defenses i don't welcome that with
nuclear capability yeah okay great job
joe yes and how did the intel people not
know senator thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else